le député de la 4e circonscription de la
sarthe c'est françois fillon qui sera le
benjamin de l'assemblée nationale le
plus jeune député de france en sorte
françois fillon rpr est âgé de 27 ans
seulement
il succède à joël le theule dont il fut
l'assistant parlementaire le rpr
françois fillon avec 51,1 % des
suffrages a été élu au premier tour
le tout jeune député est titulaire d'une
licence en droit il est diplômé de
l'institut d'études politiques
françois fillon a commencé sa carrière
politique comme attaché parlementaire à
sablé sur sarthe
cette ville où nous le retrouvons
françois fillon si je vous avais dit est
de trois ans que vous seriez aujourd'hui
jaune du pied 36 comment ils cru n'ont
certainement pas je ne m'attendais pas
du tout à être élu député à 27 ans
j'étais déjà dans l'ombre de joël depuis
cinq ans puisque j'ai été son
collaborateur chargé des dossiers
sarthois en particulier et j'espérais
bien être ce collaborateur pendant
encore de longues années
c'est donc pour moi une situation
nouvelle est une surprise la carrière
politique de françois fillon est
étroitement liée à joël le theule de 76
à 78 il fut son assistant parlementaire
avant de le suivre durant deux ans au
ministère des transports et de la
défense comme chargé de mission à son
cabinet devenu à 27 ans le benjamin de
l'assemblée il succède dès le premier
tour à joël le theule dans sa
circonscription
après une vie politique vieille de
quatre mois durant laquelle il accède au
conseil général de la sarthe riz à la
mairie de sablé comme adjoint au maire
françois fillon qui s'orientaient vers
le journalisme est conscient de la
difficulté d'assumer l'héritage d'un
homme qui a profondément marqué la vie
politique de la région il faut que bien
sûr nous poursuivions ce qu'il a
entrepris mais avec ma personnalité qui
n'est pas la sienne et avec mon
expérience mon inexpérience plus tôt
il faut donc que les les électeurs le
comprennent mais je crois que ça cette
chose qui se fera facilement